welcome back to glamour and filter taste
by me Josh knit and today we're joined
by the two stars of Amazon Prime videos
latest exclusive show little fires
everywhere Reese Witherspoon
Kerry Washington might be intro hey you
know we've got two queens in the house
and you just serve the hi speaking of hi
little flies everywhere it's coming to
Amazon Prime video on the 22nd of May
I'm bussing for it as you can tell by
the energy levels in here which I'm
obsessed with the ballet is it raises so
many important discussions that we need
to be having in our society today
especially around the concept of what
constitutes a woman right what does that
idea mean to you sat here in 2020 well I
I think about the lack of storytelling
about motherhood in general you know
just hundreds of years of lost
storytelling cuz we didn't really see it
on film very much when you know
narratives were being decided by people
who had never been mothers so Anna we
have this opportunity to create I mean
it's such a rich piece of material the
book little fires and it talks about
motherhood in so many different ways and
so many different types of mothering and
I think and really broadens broadens the
spectrum of what we we think of Mother's
you know not quintessential good mothers
or bad mothers but this whole spectrum
of behavior because this concept of a
good mother comes through the entire
narrative of this and there's so many
pressures in society even today to play
up to this idea of what constitutes a
good mother how's that played out in
your own life I think it's so important
to talk about it I think sometimes we
take for granted this idea of it because
they just sort of come down through
Society in history kind of codified
ideas but like this makes you a good
mother and different cultures have
different ideas but we just believe it
like we just buy into the story and
think like oh I have to follow
this checklist to be considered good or
bad or otherwise I love that we are that
we created this project where we
actually get to step back and think
about it and talk about it it has made
me it has made me think more about
having a little bit more compassion for
myself even as a mom especially in this
time where there's so many different
pressures right now when they ask to
click run companies run households be
teachers or teachers assistants like you
know where there's so much it's we can't
do it all publicly we actually literally
cannot do it all publicly so the kind of
re-examine that that message that we're
even supposed to is really creating an
exciting yeah and that whole concept of
the working mother is such a complex
thing because with that comes pressure
because you can't see like am i giving
enough to my career am i giving enough
to my family like is that being
difficult for you guys I'll start to get
really excited Josh when you start to
ask dads in your interviews yeah work
you know work-life balances or what it's
like to be a working dad like we don't
even use the terminology whirring dad
and I think that undervalues the role
that men play in the home to just us and
our sister working that they also don't
have pressures it's different but that
they also don't have pressures so I'll
be excited in your next interview to
watch when you're interviewing some dad
about what his work-life balance is my
job is to really just kind of do the
things that I feel called to do and
meant to do and to set that example for
my kids like guilting myself or not
chasing my dreams or making myself feel
bad or you know all of those things
would be detrimental to my role as a mom
like part of being a mom is also being
gentle and kind and loving to myself so
that my kids see that that's the example
of what we're supposed to be and strive
for oh my god for sure I'm bringing up
that point of the fact we don't ask
men in the public eye bullets like to be
a working dad because we do that dosnt
and this is obviously set in like 1997
and we've come so far in terms of
equality even since then we think of
that quite is like a recent time period
but going back to this time 1997 and
also being a person in 2020 how far do
you think we've come in that time and
actually returning to that time did you
actually like that's you you haven't
come as far as I thought we had a little
bit like we talked about the kind of Mad
Men paradigm like what happens when you
look at our world through a lens of
seeing it then and comparing it now so
if you just look through a 90s lens
there were some things that were much
more progressive and but then there were
other aspects that we talked about race
and class in a way that wasn't as
thoughtful or even acknowledging the
kind of disparity between people's lives
or the way that they were treated so
that was kind of fascinating we had to
spend a lot of time actually going you
know people didn't say that then hmm and
there were expressions that people use
like colorblind I'm colorblind which we
now know is very insensitive to to not
deny somebody part of who they are but
just playing with all of that was
actually really incredible to have those
tools and Carrie and I grew up in the
90s so we were actually teenagers in the
night so we were able to help with that
aspect of the writing as well hmm when
you think back to you in 1997 you can
set them on that zoom call and they were
here right here that's me what would you
want to say to them what kind of advice
would you want to give to them
oh my god like when you asked me that
all I want to do is hug her like you're
gonna be okay it really is gonna be okay
I think I would tell her to stay with
herself you know I think like kind of on
the journey through life I've
this times when I've abandoned myself to
be a pleaser to try to live up to
somebody else's idea of course was to be
so just like I would really invite her
to try to stay with herself as much as
possible what would you say to the 1997
you race ah don't worry so much worried
I think that I found a lot of time
worrying about things that really didn't
matter you know and I was it's not
entirely my fault culture kind of told
young women they had to worry about
things that you know what we value about
women is then is very different than
what we view about women now though I
would just say hold on sister it's about
to get a lot better yeah what kind of
things would you worry about that the
image you know not being enough not or
being too much for people my ambition
was too big my ideas were too strong I
was a little too loud too friendly to a
beat too emotional a lot of really yucky
conversations and bad situations to get
where I am and I'll say I have a million
wonderful adventures that brought me to
this place so I'm I'm an accumulation of
all those ups and downs and I'm I feel
really really strong at 44 you know 44
I've been through a lot and I've got a
lot more to go not to be not so worried
about taking up space right like with my
body with my attitude with my influence
I don't don't worry about being big it's
okay to be big and loud and bold and
even to make really big mistakes take
big risks
learn big stuff rather you know have big
tears and just do it go for it this is
one precious life is all you've got
yes because it is listen because this
idea of always saying you're to
something seems to always in media
impress in society just tend to get
attached to women more than it does to
met 160
the scent even now that's still
happening it's true it's true
for me especially I think this project
has been so much fun and so special
because there really is so much power
and partnership with women and to be
working with a woman like Ruiz who is
not afraid to take up space and who's
not afraid for the other women around
her to take up just as much space and to
have a voice as loud as hers and
instincts and input that's welcome like
it's just really so wonderful to be in
an environment where there's not
unlimited slice of the pie like you do
for all of us and all of our bigness and
that's how we cook up these exciting
creative adventures together you guys
expect your own companies you are
rewriting the rules which is what your
has tried to do in shake heights as well
what do you think it's a turning point
for you guys in setting your own rules
and what is kind of the rule that you
will continue to live by from here on
end do you think it's a good question
you know a lot of things are shifting
and changing in our business you know
we're seeing a lot of different ways
that people are consuming media the big
powerful industry Titans that were so
important when when Kari and I first
started um it's not the same everything
is shifting and that there's room for
different voices and different
perspectives and I would just say that
it's an incredible time to be an artist
a writer an actor a director I would
encourage more people who have felt like
they were other or didn't have an
opportunity to really dive in because
it's it's gonna be one of the busiest
times in our business and I think the
doors are more open than they ever have
been hmm I feel like now particularly in
this pandemic moment like we're really
all realizing how little power and
control we have because there's so much
unknown things are changing every day
but if we can just stay present with
each other like open-hearted honest
I feel like we have a shot to make it
through each day maybe moving a little
closer to who we want to be as people as
a culture of the society as a world you
know and one of the things I loved about
this narrative is it really shows how
society other people have its tools
others people and how important it is
that we are all allies to one another
how important is that message to both of
you and how's that played out in your
own lives that sense of elation I think
about that a lot it's so important to me
that young women feel supported and
mentored and every business but
particularly our our business where
media is so pervasive and it can be very
influential in young people's lives I
want to create spaces where people can
tell their stories and feel seen and
valued so it's really important to me
and partnership female partnership as
Carrie said so beautifully is so
important to me because for so many
years we were told to sort of think
about it as a competitive space that
there was scarcity and I I just don't
think that's I just don't think that's a
winning principle either
I think abundance is what I kind of
meditate on that creativity is abundant
and relationships and the ability to
create what is everlasting
but it's infinite when we partner with
each other particularly people who have
been told not to partner with each other
hey Freddie I think there's something so
special about this show now living in on
a global stage particularly in terms of
how we explore the idea of race a fool
Hirsch is a beautiful book rich ish that
I love that's all about kind of
belonging and racial identity in the UK
and and so it thinks similar to in the
US and the 90s there's this sense that
like it's better to not talk about it
it's more polite if we just avoid the
topic and fully talk about this special
ways that we come together and overcome
but not kind of dig into the deeper
themes of identity and belonging so and
we're
excited that those kinds of
conversations are gonna be able to be
had locally because it's not an issue
solely in the United States that's
really well said too and I also would
add on to that I would say it's a great
show to watch with your teenage kids
because it does talk about race
sexuality class and you're not talking
with your children about those things
they're talking to somebody else and
getting ideas from somebody else so it's
a great conversation starter sometimes
it's easier to watch a show my mom used
to do that my mom every week used to
watch - I know - I know with me week
plans and I was like the coolest mom
ever but she shared looking back that it
just it meant we could talk about
drinking and drugs and sex it wasn't
about me and my friends it was about
those characters on TV which was such a
smart parenting approach on her part
and there was one last thing I went to
Oskie this is obviously all about middle
fires creating big blazing fires is
there a little fire that happened in
your lives there's actually become a
very big empowering fire
I'm sure instead of complaining about a
problem like I'm I tell a story about
how I read a terrible script and it made
me start a company because so poorly
written and it was just terrible that I
thought women deserves so much better
better roles better opportunities in our
business so that definitely was like
that script little fire inside of me who
knows why was that script that moment
that I was like if I don't start doing
producing myself this is just gonna get
worse and worse or the girls that come
after me what about you Carrie I feel
like the time's up movement husband that
as well right like there were these tiny
little fires not tiny for each of our
individual lives they were these
cataclysmic fires but that we made tiny
and not sharing them with each other in
the world or
the world made tiny by ignoring us or
quieting us and as we came together as
women all over the world and across
industries we've been able to say times
up together and be part of a movement
this is all about building bridges
within communities little fires
everywhere that's how we keep doing that
building those bridges even though we're
more disconnected than ever which is the
sad reality of the situation but it's
still possible right no but we're still
I mean it's what's interesting is we
have to choose connection now we can't
take our connections for granted now we
have to really choose to spend time and
not necessarily space but emotional
space so we're connected it's just
different
I think that's so well said Carrie adds
real smart time we do these interviews I
just look at her I think is pure fire
you guys keep spreading these flames
Thank You Josh and we're so excited for
everybody over there to see it we can't
wait to see the response this response
in America was so fun to watch so we
can't wait to see the tweets and all the
comments yeah and obviously it's
difficult when you play a character
people hate right I've never died so fun
for me people never watched me before it
oh great hey guys on this show really
it's intense
well good luck with the Twitter hey hey
you know we'll need it and stay safe
it's been great speaking to you Thank
You Josh
good to see you honey thank you so much
you